So I'm with my daughter last night in the kitchen
she's gonna be 10.
And she's like oh my God, I can't believe the host
of Jeopardy is coming on your show.
And I was like oh my God, if you only knew.
Like we've known you through so many iterations.
How does it feel to now wear this new crown?
And doesn't it actually matriculate back to your son
as an origin point.
So for Jeopardy, you know this is like I mean
you've experienced these as well.
Things that you did not plan that happened
and then change your life.
Yeah.
And my son was,
you know on the internet like they tend to be,
and he said mama people are saying
you should guest host Jeopardy.
And this was when Jeopardy was having guest hosts
after Alex Trebek passed away.
And I said that's not true.
And he said they said, they're saying it on social media.
So I called my agent, I called Richard Whites.
And I said, my son said that he saw something
on social media that I should guest how host Jeopardy
and Richard Whites was like I'm on it, I'm on it.
And I said but are you really?
Like why is my son the first one to,
anyway Richard Whites then called me a couple weeks later
and he's like you're gonna guest host Jeopardy.
So that's how that started.
And through, you know, a series of twists and turns
and you know, fascinating things I ended up with more than
just a guest hosting gig.
And I was, I already have a full time job.
I'm on a show called Call Me Kat.
We're doing our second season.
So I have a full time job.
We talked about that last time you were here.
And, and I'm, you know
I've been balancing these things for about a year.
You know, we're finishing our second season of Call Me Kat
and then Jeopardy happened.
And then I wrote this script, you know, six years ago,
and never thought it would turn into a movie
and just everything happened this year is what happened.
So last summer it was, you know, pre-vaccination.
We filmed this movie with Dustin Hoffman
and Candace Bergen and Diana Agron and Simon Helberg.
(applause)
I mean, they do say and I really love this saying so much
that I actually wrote out a neon sign
and created it and made it with this company.
And I hung it in my entryway and it says
timing is everything.
Yep.
So all of this was incubating.
And the time obviously is now.
Talk to me about this movie.
Why did you write it six years ago?
Why is it personal for you?
How did you get this cast?
The, the last one I'm still trying to figure out.
It feels very very surreal.
About, my father died seven years ago,
and there's a traditional year of mourning
in observant Judaism.
And after that year,
a lot of things kind of tend to open up.
It's a very kind of closed year.
Are you sitting shiva that whole time?
So no, you sit shiva for, for seven days,
but there are restrictions in traditional Judaism
for the year.
I didn't listen to music for a year.
There are certain events you don't go to, it's,
there's a lot of very elaborate things
that are meant to sort of make it a year of focus
and introspection.
Indeed it was.
But when that year ended I felt a desire to write
and to write out thoughts and memories.
And a lot of music was coming to me from my childhood.
I never thought I'm gonna turn this into a movie.
I just thought well I'm a writer
and I better put it down on paper.
I sat on it for a long time.
Finally got the courage to show it to a few people
close to me.
And I sent the script, never thinking that I would get
these actors and Simon Helberg I knew from Big Hang Theory.
I thought he'd say well Mayim, that's very sweet.
And I remember when your father passed away and I'm sorry,
but he wanted to do it.
And Dustin and Candace and Diana,
they all said we feel very moved by this script
and Dustin was not a fan of Big Bang Theory, which is fine.
He had never seen it, I think.
And he said, how'd you get into directing Miss Bialik?
I said, well, funny thing Mr. Hoffman,
this is the first thing I've ever written.
And he said, that's not true.
And I said, yes it is.
Wow.
And he did the movie and really really felt moved by
the story and seeing him and Candace together
was absolutely incredible.
I'm so glad that you turned it into this beautiful movie
that is so gorgeous.
It really sweeps you off your feet and it's again,
why the Dustin Hoffmans
and the Candace Bergens are like, sure.
It's like they're the best actors.
They know good.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
I appreciate that very much.
Truly, it's such a beautiful movie.
(applause)
(upbeat music)